hey friends Justine and I recently got a
chance to try out the Vision Pro now to
be completely transparent with you I
have tried it four times now and each
time was a little bit different and each
time was a different sort of experience
I asked you guys if you had any
questions so I'm going to go through and
answer a few but I guess before I do
that my initial experience with it was
at WWDC and it was unlike anything I had
experienced inside of any type of VR AR
headset because it it's like just the
Apple Way like they just have this way
of capturing something unique and
delivering it in such a manner where
you're just like okay I I understand now
I see the appeal I think the thing
that's going to be kind of difficult for
launch is like what are you actually
going to do with it because I still feel
like developers are still creating so it
is pretty early so the main thing that I
feel like most people are going to be
doing is consuming content and it's a
really incredible experience I will say
that we watched a trailer
of Star Wars and I was able to watch it
on an immersive environment on Tatooine
it I actually got a little emotional but
I was like okay I don't want to cry
inside of my headset here like I was
sitting there you know in just an
environment that felt like I was on
another planet watching the Star Wars
trailer and that was just it was It was
kind of unbelievable to be honest with
you the other thing that's cool are the
subtleties when someone starts talking
to you
you can look at them and they'll kind of
just fade into view so that would be the
point that they would actually be able
to see your eyes so that was also
something that was just kind of
unbelievable is being able to see
somebody's eyes through the display and
what's interesting is it kind of looks
like you're actually looking at their
eyes but it is a digital replica of the
emotions and things that like your face
is doing projected onto the screen
because you can't see through it it's
just mimicking what you're doing and it
was so realistic like it actually
creeped me out because I was like those
eyes like they're not yours but like
they look exactly like them so it's like
my mind could not differentiate between
the fact that it wasn't real so that was
actually pretty awesome in that same
demo when kind of looking at like the
eyesight is if somebody is looking at a
piece of content the screen will kind of
start like blurring or be a different
color so you'll know that they can't
actually see you but when they kind of
come back to view and you're looking at
somebody that's when you'll be able to
see their eyes so there is that
connection that lets you know when you
know you're being acknowledged or if
they're you inside of a film or they're
scrolling a website or whatever like
it's it's pretty wild I think most
people have been asking if it's heavy
and I'm not going to lie to you it is it
is a heavy headset but most of the time
I've just been using the kind of solo
knit Loop and not the one that kind of
goes over top of your head so I really
think that that's going to make a huge
difference I also have a apparently a
smaller head because a lot of comments
were like Justin why does that look so
big on your head and not so big on
others and like well I I mean that's
just relativity I guess that's just how
it happens there is going to be a
fitting process so that you will get the
right size headsets and another question
that a lot of people were asking is if
you wear contacts or glasses you are
able to get Zeiss Optical lenses which
it doesn't come I think directly from
Apple it comes from Zeiss so they are
able to take your prescription and
they'll be able to ship you the correct
inserts for that so I probably will
order myself a set of the inserts mostly
because I feel like if I'm going to be
using this this is going to be like I'm
chilling I'm lounging like I don't want
to have to wear my contacts if I don't
actually have to have them in I'm just
I'm relaxing and I feel like for me this
is going to be that type of device I
don't really know how it's going to fit
into my life so I really kind of look
forward to seeing how this all evolves
because I honestly don't know and I feel
like a lot of people don't know and
that's kind of the history behind it I
think developers and consumers and the
demand for a specific thing for this I
guess we kind of you know push the
industry that way so I I'm definitely
excited to try that out so let me just
go into some of the questions so Hawaii
is asking about creating spatial videos
for Vision Pro with the iPhone 15 Pro
you are able to record spatial video and
it basically is using the top two lenses
and recording it simultaneously so I
haven't tried to edit that footage and I
don't think right now that Final Cut
supports it but obviously Final Cut is
an Apple app so if for some reason they
don't support editing spatial video then
I don't really know what to say I do
feel like that'll be coming it has to be
like it just has to be now I did get a
chance to shoot and view some of my
content in the headset so I think the
biggest piece of advice that I would say
for most people is you don't have to
really worry about like moving the
camera around too much it does do a
really good job of stabilizing it but I
would just kind of try to stay you know
like not super still but just don't go
wild like running around because I mean
I know for me I get motion sickness very
easily so that is not the type of
content that I want to watch so I'm
going to try my best any type of content
that I shoot I will make sure that like
I'm not getting super wild and out of
control you do have to keep the phone
like pretty far away to really get a
good shot because if you're filming and
like there's a face like super close
that face is going to be super close in
the headset and it's unsettling so I did
find that I was able to shoot spatial
video of myself and it it turned out
okay so as long as I held this out as
far as I possibly could it was just the
right kind of distance away that it
wasn't super overpowering so it will be
kind of interesting to see how you know
vlogging goes in spatial video as for
where you can post it I definitely think
if you aird drop it to somebody it will
keep that metadata intact but I I don't
know about posting online I don't think
YouTube supports it yet this is still
early so I do imagine the websites will
be supporting spatial videos soon
hopefully fingers crossed Deb V is
asking how good the ear side speakers
are the speakers were shockingly good I
was actually surprised because it almost
felt like I was wearing headphones or
airpods or something but I wasn't it was
just the speakers coming right out the
Vision Pro and it was super impressive
does the eye tracking eliminate any
dizzy feelings so I really haven't got
to use it for extended periods of time I
never really felt dizzy the pass through
through video so like you can kind of
see around you it's super fast so like
when you're walking around like it feels
like you're walking around in the real
world the only thing that is strange is
it like tricks your brain because you're
looking out at a screen but like it's
the real world so your brain knows that
you're looking at the real world but
your eyes are still seeing the screen so
the only thing that feels different is
there's like this slight eye fatigue of
when you're like looking at a screen or
you're you know working a lot on like
your phone or something like that you
still have that just digital eye strain
feeling the dread day is asking how long
do you think people will be able to wear
it continuously before fatigue I think
that's going to be a personal thing I
feel like it's something that you might
have to get used to and work up to I
know anytime I use have used the meta
Quest or even uh Playstation VR2 I don't
do a lot in VR so for me every time I do
use it it's an adjustment period so I do
feel that the longer that I use it every
other day I feel like I kind of get used
to it more so I think this is going to
be along those same lines and I
definitely don't recommend somebody just
kind of like popping in this and like
spending the entire day the first day
that you get it I think it's something
that you do need to ease your way into
because it is a completely different
experience and there's so much
stimulation that it it made my brain
just tired from just experiencing so
much information so fast
that I think that's going to be the
thing that's going to be fatiguing for
people not necessarily wearing it it's
just the over stimulation of so much
content so quickly I do think that the
strap that you'll be able to get which
actually does come with it is going to
help out so much with how heavy the
headset is because it is it I mean it is
heavy but it feels premium it feels
really well made but it's it is heavy
especially for my my small little face
silly Mikey says do you see yourself
wearing one regularly or more of a
situational thing I don't know TBD I do
think that obviously because it's going
to be a new device I probably will wear
it pretty frequently and I guess
depending upon the different types of
things that come out for it I don't know
it we're going to see but I'm excited to
kind of go on this journey is it worth
$3,500 um I mean that's hard to say that
is a lot of money and plus with taxes
it's probably going to be about $4,000
but it is kind of its own Standalone
device so don't really think of it as a
companion I guess it is kind of a
companion into your phone or your
MacBook but I guess for some people this
essentially could possibly you know
replace your computer depending upon the
things that you do or replace your iPad
or something like that if we're talking
in sort of those types of metrics but it
is a very expensive device and of course
it is new it's the first of its kind so
I think that is to be expected and of
course coming from Apple having this be
their Pro premium device down the line
maybe there will be an apple Vision not
pro Eric is asking if I'm going to
actually answer any questions
yes any rumors of Beats collaboration
limited edition Vision OS devices
something that might get two columns in
Vogue the way that I don't I don't know
I don't know what you're referring to
but I like that thought have I tried it
with the over thehead strap I have not
yes no I did did I try I don't now I
don't remember I think I did I'm did I
my memory is absolutely terrible I don't
know I'll get back to you Charlie is
asking about best practices for shooting
spatial videos should I hold my eye at
eye level to mimic the natural movement
of my head locked off tripod shots to
minimize movement or something else I
think just making slow movements keeping
things further in the distance maybe a
little bit further than kind of like
your hand so that it doesn't feel super
close the spatial video setting will
tell you when you should move back from
an object which is great because it kind
of gives you that distance just to let
you know like okay this is too far this
is too close and it'll kind of give you
that visual representation on the screen
if you're too close to something I don't
think you necessarily have to keep it on
a tripod because it does a really great
job of keeping everything stabilized
John says did it spark Joy actually it
did and the type of joy that it sparked
for me was this childlike just wonder
because it was something that I had
really never experienced seeing like my
Apple ecosystem right before my eyes
being able to pinch and just grab a
window Bring It Forward and bring it
back and so quickly and so smoothly the
intuitiveness and just the smooth
interface and just the way that you
interact with things it really is it's
it's it's wonderful MB asks how do TV
shows look how comfortable is it to wear
TV shows and stuff look amazing I mean
it really is an entertainment viewing
experience and what's so awesome is
their immersive environments like
360°
of beauty and they have like the sounds
of that immersive experience so you know
I was at this um like Lookout in Hawaii
and I've actually been to this Lookout
in real life so for me kind of looking
at this in this whole new way it's it's
really emotional and even watching like
my own content that I've shot it was
like reliving these things for the
second time kind of mind-blowing Jay is
asking if I can feed my goo pets in
Vision Pro that's actually a good
question I do know that I did open up an
iPad app in Vision Pro so there there
are obviously apps that are specific for
Vision Pro but when I opened up one of
the iPad apps it looked almost exactly
like just you would imagine it just
opened up and I was able to use it
interact with it and the other cool
thing when you're browsing the web in
Safari and you see a link somewhere you
just kind of look around and if you want
to click on it you just you just look at
it and you click on it it's almost like
you're using your mind to control and
it's such a weird experience I think
somebody asked me about the virtual
keyboard let me get to your question
somebody asked me about it I don't know
where it went anyway um whoever asked
about the virtual keyboard you can have
this little keyboard pop up and when you
look at the
bottom right corner you can move it
around so like if I look at the bottom
corner I'm able to just move that
keyboard forward towards me and this is
where it messes with your mind because
you can actually type on the virtual
keyboard but it gives you this weird
sensation I don't know how it happens
it's kind of like a little little haptic
feedback it's just it's the strangest
feeling cuz I'm like I know there's
nothing in front of me but I'm touching
the keyboard and I still feel
something it's wild also what's cool is
you can use your voice in Safari there's
like a little microphone that you can go
and look at it click it and then you can
use your voice to go to websites you can
also use your voice to type when you
have the keyboard popped up so there's
all these other different things you
don't actually have to type but the
typing was kind of fun um Aus is asking
how the motion sickness was for me it
has been a problem with other VR
headsets I didn't feel any motion
sickness I mean I wasn't playing any
games or really doing anything super
intense I was kind of seated most of the
time I did get a chance to try out this
one app where they brought in this huge
like um race car and you could pull it
apart it felt so real like I was kind of
shocked like when this thing just
plopped down it was like a life-size
race car and you could take it apart so
every time I would look at a piece I
would just grab it and flick it I would
look at something I took the whole thing
apart you could take the wheels off I
feel like this is a really cool demo for
education so if I wanted to learn about
I me maybe even like doing like surgery
or things like that like you could
really get a a very realistic view of a
body or like doing surgery or even just
fixing cars or mechanics or things like
this so honestly this is going to be a
really great device for educational
purposes is the cord an issue uh did not
seem like one I had Pockets at the time
so when I did get up and walk around I
just SLI the little pack into my pockets
even though the headset was kind of
heavy like I still was able to look
around look down like it wasn't falling
off the cord seemed perfectly fine like
I didn't even know it was there actually
Zach is saying that it looks uncomfy
actually it's not it was surprisingly
comfortable I know we keep talking about
how heavy it is but for the way that the
weight distributes on your face the
cushion is so soft like which keeps the
light from getting into the the headset
and I really do think that once we get
the top head strap it's going to make a
huge difference for the comfort levels
but yeah it's it's actually pretty
comfortable and I've worn a lot of
different types of headsets Ram is
asking about my overall experience how
long did I keep it on each time was I
mean it was definitely no more than 30
minutes but the experience was great and
every experience was different so I
cannot wait to actually get my hands on
this thing and get to experience it for
myself and really test it out just the
scrolling through of like photos and the
one thing that was shocking is if you're
not taking panorama photos you need to
be taking them I stopped taking them
like in 2018 or 2015 after like I don't
know it was a thing they were awesome it
was probably one of my like top things
that I did was get to test this out Ian
is asking if I shot any videos with the
device I did not but that is something
that I'm very excited because you can
actually use the headset to shoot
spatial videos so that's going to be
super cool to test out are you
surrounded by 360 or do you see black
edges on the sides so this is
interesting because on the little
digital Crown you're able to scale up
how much you see and scale back so if
you're in one of these immersive
environments you can scale it so you
don't feel completely immersed and like
the world will kind of just shrink and
it'll all kind of fade so you'll still
see the real world you'll still see the
immersive environment or if you want to
just not see anything you can turn that
dial all the way up and be fully immerse
and it's definitely worth it the cool
thing though is you can still see your
hands so that kind of keeps you in
reality if you know what I mean like you
can see your hands you can move around
so it doesn't make you feel like you're
you're just cut off from the world like
it's here so it looks like that is all
the questions that I have other than
everyone asking me if I could buy them
one no I'm not going to buy you one oh I
also like this this one is there it is
again it's the new Apple gang symbol
Vision Pro you know it there it is I
guess in closing the coolest thing that
I kind of experienced was was just the
way that you could look at something and
interact with it and how accurate and
precise that Vision was like when you
look at something like you see it you
pinch it you got it and it also doesn't
really matter where you have your hands
I mean I'm sure you can't like have them
like over your head or I'm not really
sure what the limit is but for the most
part no matter where I had my hands if I
just had them sitting or resting in my
lap I could just pinch like I didn't
have to make it a thing like we didn't
have to be like up here just so I could
select something you can just be sitting
resting and you could just pinch because
there are sensors right on like the
bottom so it'll pick you up like
wherever you are so I think that was
kind of just the coolest thing like how
accurate it was so yeah I guess that's
it I guess if you have any other
questions feel free to leave them in the
comments below and if there's anything
that you'd like me to test out when I
actually get a device to review I would
love to hear it and it's also going to
be interesting to review too because
it's it's going to be so much content
inside my head so it's going to be fun
to kind of figure out a way it's to be
able to share with you guys what I'm
seeing because it is something that you
I think really have to go to the Apple
store and just try it because it is so
awesome and I look forward to seeing
what you guys think so if you haven't
already be sure to subscribe and hit the
Bell to be notified when I post a new
video so you guys will be the first to
see when I get one of these to be able
to review it I cannot wait I guess I'll
see you guys in Vision
Pro